so there's this cosmological Einstein's
cosmological constant that now hides
this thing that we don't understand
called Dark Energy what's dark energy
what's your best guess at what this
thing is
why do we think it's there
it's because this is comes from the
astronomers
dark energy is synonymous with positive
cosmological constant
and
um
uh we think it's there
because the astronomers have told us
it's there
and
um
they they know what they're doing and we
don't know really really hard
measurement but they know they really
know what they're doing
and
we have no freaking idea why it's there
another big mystery another another
reason it's fun to be a physicist and if
it is there why should it be so small
why should there be so little why should
it have hit itself from us
why shouldn't there enough be enough of
it to substantially cons curve the space
between us and the Moon why did there
have to be such a
small amount that only the crazy best
astronomers in the world could find it